[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des télégrammes du monde entier sont
allés trouver dans sa retraite
méditerranéenne
le nouveau lauréat du prix nobel de
littérature ce prix mondial couronne
cette année le poète saint john perse
qui fut dans le civil ambassadeur sous
le nom d'alexis léger grand honneur pour
les lettres françaises qui figurent pour
la dixième fois sur un palmarès où l'on
peut lire entre autres les noms d'albert
camus françois mauriac andré gide et
romain rolland les honneurs mérités
car on peut considérer ce un jeune père
ce comme le plus grand poète français
vivant
[Musique]
la visite au centre nucléaire de saclay
constitué l'une des visites techniques
du séjour du président de la république
malgache monsieur tir and hot pour trois
jours de la france qui accueillait ainsi
officiellement pour la première fois
l'un des chefs d'état de la communauté
la soirée de gala à l'opéra en a
constitué l'apothéose le président
tsiranana général de gaulle madame cyr
année madame de gaulle a accueilli par
deux petits rats avaient rendez vous
avec le tout paris le rendez vous de
l'amitié de deux pays
[Musique]
devant le palais de la mutualité au
rendez-vous de l'unef
quinze mille étudiants étaient venus
pour participer à un meeting réclamant
une paix négociée en algérie 3000 agents
y étaient également venus pour faire
respecter l'interdiction de manifester
dans la rue
[Musique]
bilan une centaine de blessés qui
n'étaient pas tous étudiants en effet la
qualité de journaliste pourtant
apparente n'a pas protégé une quinzaine
de reporter
[Musique]
ces images ont quatre ans ça n'est pas
assez pourtant pour qu'on les ait
complètement oublié le drame de budapest
jeté vers la frontière autrichienne
défilent d'hommes de femmes et d'enfants
fuyons une ville dont la révolte serait
étouffée par les chars soviétiques
c'était pour eux voici quatre ans le
début d'un exil douloureux
aujourd'hui à paris dans un cours de
dessin industriel où ils réapprennent un
métier pour continuer à vivre
voici un ancien pharmacien un ancien
professeur d'éducation physique
une ancienne femme d'un tel autre est
aujourd'hui mêler aux ouvriers qui
sortent d'une usine de la région
parisienne
il possède un métier et il a retrouvé sa
place dans la vie
tel autre enfin qui continue ses études
de chimie a fondé un foyer mais sa jeune
femme une française ne connaît que des
photos de sa famille pas d'oubli pour
eux entre le passé et le présent il y a
une frontière
une vraie
[Applaudissements]
l'héritage de cyrus c'est ce pays dont
téhéran la capitale avec ses immeubles
modernes et ses cent mille auto mais
aussi ses deux millions d'habitants de
toute classe offre une première image
mais très imparfaite
voici un an bientôt le chat lui donnait
comme rennes la jeune étudiante farhadi
da au milieu d'un luxe de mille et une
nuits de cette union est née aujourd'hui
l'héritier du trône désirer depuis 22
ans farah diba a voulu qu'il naquit dans
cette clinique de téhéran où l'on
assisté le docteur salem ministre de la
santé et huit infirmières
particulièrement choisi
[Musique]
la succession dynastique est donc assuré
le prince régnera sur cet empire grand
trois fois comme la france peuplé de 20
millions d'âmes qui se situe à la
jointure du monde oriental et qui tient
en deux dimensions 2500 et 1000 km entre
les colonne brisée de persépolis et les
cheminées des raffinerie d'abadan
[Musique]
les 2500 ans coexistent sur cette terre
les lavandières qui fument le narguilé
sont aussi bien d'hyères que
d'aujourd'hui et les dom orgueilleux ou
modeste 10 par an ne se rajeunissent que
des pylônes primitif de la toute neuve
électricité
[Musique]
les voûtes des anciens palais abrite
aujourd'hui les éventaires des petits
artisans qui accomplissent les mêmes
geste sinon les mêmes ouvrages qu'au
temps du grand cyrus les dynasties son
nord mais les métiers ont gardé la vie
et les peintures qui rappellent les
changes d'ambassadeur avec louis xiv ne
sont plus que le décor d'un atelier de
tissage
il y aura toujours des petits seront
sans doute dans ce pays des tapis car à
chiraz les enfants dès l'école
brandissent des métiers à leur taille
mais il ya autre chose en iran le caviar
de la caspienne par exemple le plus
apprécié du monde ce caviar dans la
production annuelle atteint 140 tonnes
dont 130 sont destinés à l'exportation
nous sommes à l'autre bout des 2500 ans
car on construit des routes en iran on
essaye de mettre le pays à un rythme
mois sur année tout la juxtaposition des
engins modernes et de la vieille massada
mai
d'où aussi la naissance de ce
gigantesque barrage du cfi rude qui sera
l'un des plus importants de lorient
construit par des français ceci dans le
village voisin où gardait des habitudes
cher pétanque café et belote
si loin c'est à la fois respectable et
touchant
et il ya le pétrole l'iran at on dit est
une île flottant sur une mer de pétrole
le pétrole qui fait la richesse et le
péril de l'iran car toute la fortune du
pays repose sur ces forages sur ses
raffineries
sur cette production et ses réserves qui
le place au quatrième rang dans le monde
du pétrole
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
c'est sur ce lac de pétrole que l'iran
danse comme ils dansent est sans doute
déjà voici deux mille ans n'est le temps
à marcher si la question dynastique est
résolu par la naissance du jeune prince
qui porte le nom de cyrus d'autres
problèmes se posent problème social le
peuple iranien vit dans la pauvreté sur
un sol trop riche problème politique
l'iran est l'une des charnières entre
l'est et l'ouest
équipe i charnière dis danger bien que
l'iran se soient rangés dans le camp
occidental et que l'amérique les doter
d'une armée moderne
'nos coup projette sur cet avant poste
une grande ombre et est l'héritier du
trône quand il ouvrira les yeux sur le
ciel y verra d'abord des escadrilles
ce petit avion vous le connaissez bien
sans le savoir c'est celui de l'écrivain
du sienne
vous avez tous vu tracé sur fond d'azur
ces lettres de fumer mais qui se doutent
de la rigueur et de la complexité du
plan de vol que nécessite l'écriture
d'un seul mot tracé à l'envers dans le
ciel pour être lus du sol à l'endroit
c'est pourquoi le premier travail de
jacques fage qui est en france le
pionnier des écrivains du ciel commence
à l'intérieur du simulateur de vol par
tâtonnement
c'est là qu'il va réaliser en réduction
ce qu'on pourrait appeler son brouillon
[Musique]
ainsi mise au point en chambre chaque
mouvement d'appareil nécessaire pour
obtenir les éléments d'une lettre la
lettre a par exemple jacques rage va se
borner à le répéter au cours de ces
évolutions en plein ciel l'oeil
uniquement fixés sur son plan de vol
d'une part sur son compas gyroscopique
et son chronomètre d'autre part il
réalise alors un vol sans visibilité
ainsi à une minute 57
l'appareil va amorcer un virage presque
cap pour cap attaque et 10 secondes de
ligne droite et nous verrons du sol
apparaître le dernier gens d'âge du m
à 4000 mètres d'altitude l'écrivain du
ciel façonne sans rien avoir des figures
de 600 m qui deviennent pour nous les
lettres de l'alphabet singulier métier
que celui de jacques fage nouvel
écrivain public salle à pouvoir se
vanter de réunir en quelques minutes
deux millions cinq cent mille lecteurs
et singulier métier que celui d'écrivain
du ciel né avec notre époque fille de la
technique et de la publicité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]